if there is a place offering safety and
security it lies hundreds of kilometers
to the west
and the people of eastern ukraine will
do their best to reach it
but the roads are congested and the
checkpoints are overwhelmed with cues of
three kilometers or more
at the train station in kramertorsk a
long line of hopeful passengers leads
out the door
and on platform number one we witness
scenes of order
and pandemonium the two in constant
competition
but as the russians move east the people
of this city are getting out
why do you feel you have to leave
the governor of the region of donetsk
has told residents to leave he's worried
they'll get in the way of his soldiers
but it isn't easy to relocate your life
just ask tatiana and best friend rocky
do you know where you're going do you
have a plan
now
environment
there are two trains expected
one at one o'clock one at four o'clock
both tel aviv they may or may not arrive
we're not sure yet but there are too
many people here
to fit inside those trains and it has
been like that for the last couple of
days
a moment of relief arrived on a chair in
the crowded booking hall
his name is father
and he offered a few words
then a woman asked him to sing mr
vakarchuk is ukraine's most popular
entertainer
[Music]
when the day comes the war will be over
hug me hug me he's saying
[Music]
why did you come why did you come here
to speak to people because i want them
to make sure to be sure
that they're not alone so the whole
country
stands together with them
these are the best people in the world
i'm so proud of these these guys i mean
all of them are
these are heroes
the ukrainian military will be tested in
the days and weeks ahead
for the russians have set their sights
on eastern ukraine and after a series of
failures president putin will expect
results we spoke to the regional
governor have you seen
evidence that the russian military is
reinforcing
its positions in the east
island
the people of this region know what's
coming
and they've seen what's happened in
communities surrounding kiev
this trip an act of necessity
not an act of choice
john sparks sky news in kramertorsk